- Usually, in companies,
there's a notion of
a hierarchy, a set of
objectives, a quarterly plan,
and so we had none of that.
There's always people smarter than you.
There's always people who just
think more clearly than you.
And if you can find such a
person, align yourself with them.
As a general statement about society,
we need to ask the harder questions,
and we need to ask for stronger solutions.
And one of the engineers, his name is Ron,
pounds the table and said,
"That would be evil!"
And I'm like, oh, okay,
what just happened?
- He's an American software
engineer, businessperson,
and Executive Chairman of Alphabet.
From 2001 to 2011, he
served as CEO of Google.
In 2016, Forbes ranked him
as the 100th richest person
in the world, with a fortune
of 10.8 billion dollars.
He's Eric Schmidt, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule #10 is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Eric is talking,
if he says something
that really resonates with you,
leave it in the comments,
and put it in quotes,
so that other people can
be inspired, as well!
- Usually, in companies,
there's a notion of
a hierarchy, a set of
objectives, a quarterly plan,
sort of, we had none of that.
Our theory was that the leadership,
and particularly the
bottoms-up leadership,
really should be empowered
by what we were doing,
and we'd see how far they get.
We didn't have an 18-month strategy,
we just kept iterating.
So what I learned from this
is that fast iteration is the key.
The most important thing
to do is, every week,
a new product, a new
idea, just keep pushing.
You'd be amazed how much progress you make
in three months or six months.
- The background that you had, you know,
working at Novell, working at
Bell Labs, working at Xerox.
To that point in your career
when you met Larry and Sergey,
I wonder what led you to
choose that opportunity next?
What about them was so
different that made you say,
okay, this is the next thing for me to do?
- In my case, I'd been working at Novell,
and I was invited to
visit Larry and Sergey.
They invited me to their little office.
They had all this food on the table,
which had been prepared
by the Google chef,
which I thought was rather odd.
And they had my background
on the whiteboard,
which they were projecting.
And they proceeded to examine me,
in terms of my ideas and the
technology we were building,
which they disagreed with completely.
And I thought, well,
that's a very nice meeting.
And I realized, as I left,
and it was, curiously,
in an old Sun building,
that it was the most
interesting conversation
I'd had in a decade.
And that's why I joined.
- Could it have gone another way?
Was there a moment that
you looked at that,
as you look back on that, and said,
if this had happened, I
wouldn't have taken it,
or if this had happened,
I wouldn't have gotten it.
Are there moments like that?
- I think, from my perspective,
is I'd already run a large organization.
I wanted to work at a very small,
very, very smart organization,
and I figured Google would be that.
God knows it came out differently.
But what I learned in this process is that
there's always people smarter than you.
There's always people who just
think more clearly than you.
And if you can find such a
person, align yourself with them.
In this case, these two young men,
they're in their 20s, right?
And they're awfully precocious.
And I haven't had that tough an argument
from such young men in a long time,
and I thought, this is it.
You know, you just knew.
And these people are rare.
And we now know them as the
great founders in our industry,
and I'm sure some of them
are here in the audience.
You find such a person, work with them,
work for them, manage
them, do whatever it takes.
- [Interviewer] When
someone's pitching you,
what don't you want to hear?
Everyone asks what you do.
What don't you want to hear?
- I want to hear that everybody is focused
on this new architecture,
and anybody who's coming in
with plans based on the
earlier architectures,
you're not going to make it.
You need to be on scalable
plans that solve real problems.
It's so easy to solve a local problem;
you need to dream bigger.
Over and over again, we
hear ideas that interesting
in a local context, but
they're not big enough.
So dream bigger, right?
As a general statement about society,
we need to ask the harder questions,
and we need to ask for stronger solutions.
There is a global
emerging consensus around
issues and so forth.
Together, we're very strong.
The people you hire to find the culture,
whether you like it or not.
So Larry and Sergey, when
they started the company,
said we need to have really smart people,
so they hired a rocket scientist,
and they hired a medical doctor.
And they hired a Stanford graduate
who'd been a professional football player,
'cause they figured that they wanted
normal people who'd done
something exceptional.
So in my case, I was a pilot,
and I had done other things,
and they said, "Okay, you're good enough."
You know, the CEO has to have something
besides being a CEO that
makes them interesting.
And everyone had something.
I would go around, and I'd say,
"Well, what's special about you?"
It's like Sesame Street, you know?
What's special about you,
and what's special about you?
But there was always an interesting story.
So another lesson I learned
is that you don't hire generic people.
You hire people who've
had some kind of stress
or achievement or whatever.
The best people to hire, by the way,
are CFOs who've gone bankrupt.
'Cause boy have they been through the war.
And on the CFO side, and the finance side,
you want somebody who's
not going to happen again.
And you only go bankrupt once, by the way.
- I'd like to ask you a general
question for all businesses.
If you were coaching a
business class, or a company,
how does a company remain nimble today?
What do we have to do to remain nimble?
- My problem with most
strategy conversations
is that they're always inward-out.
You know, we establish, well, first,
we're the best in the world,
'cause everybody thinks that.
Which can't possibly be true.
And second, we see that
all of our products
are going to be successful, and therefore
we'll be very successful in the future.
And that's usually how
strategy is done in businesses.
I prefer a completely different approach.
Work very, very, very hard to figure out
what the world's going to
look like in five years.
What will people be doing?
What will your customers want?
Where costs will be.
In our case, what will networks look like?
How important will phones be?
What will the apps look like?
Web services?
And spend an awful lot of time on that,
and then take a look at your offerings.
What are the strongest ones,
which are the ones that are
going to iterate quickly.
You're probably gone do fine there,
you understand these businesses.
What about these others?
If you think about, in the media business,
there are media businesses
that are going very well,
and others that are in great trouble.
This was completely predicted
five years ago, right?
So the leaders in the
ones that are in trouble
should have, right, done a
five-year plan, and said,
"Holy cow, what are we going to do?
"What are the things we can do?"
Or maybe we sell ourselves,
or we try something different.
But almost all of these strategic shifts
are predictable using my five year model.
Almost nobody does a five-year plan.
Most business do a one- to two-year plan.
Especially in our space.
But even in businesses, the only business
that I discovered that does
a five-year or longer plan
is the oil and gas industry.
And the reason is because
they have to deploy
so much capital and do all this planning.
But even there, they have trouble,
because the prices go up
and down and so forth,
so even there, it's difficult.
- What would you tell a
founder they should do
to protect and to hold onto their equity?
What advice would you give them?
- I can always tell when we're
dealing with a proper founder
when we start with how are
they spending their money.
And so whenever I go into a startup
that has beautiful offices and
really nice chairs, I cringe.
'Cause that means that they
haven't quite figured out
that it's not their money.
Unless it is their money, in which case
they can waste it on that.
When I joined Google,
I was given an office and I
had a little corner of a desk
with four other engineers.
Eventually I was given an 8x12 office,
where my desk was a door with...
Hobbyhorses, whatever they are.
- [Interviewer] Like the
tabletop was your door?
- The table top, literally a door.
Which I've retained,
to try to remind myself
of what it takes to be successful,
so my office today has that door in it.
The great founders are frugal.
They understand that the
money needs to be used
precisely for certain areas.
Many of the most successful founders
begin with no salary at all.
I have lots of stories
about Larry and Sergey,
but let's just say that when I started,
one of them was having
trouble with his car,
so I had loan him my car
'cause his car broke down.
I mean, that's the kind of
stuff we're talking about.
So if you're not prepared to live that,
you don't really understand
what being a founder's like.
For me, I'd love to be a founder,
I'd love to have a nice corner
office with a beautiful view,
and lots of secretaries, and all this art.
That's not how it works, right?
And the great founders
always started that way.
So that should give you some data.
I don't agree that you
should narrow your focus.
What I believe is that
you get the best outcome
when you make the broadest appeal
in terms of leadership and
excitement and so forth.
And we worked very hard
to make that happen.
But there were other things.
For example, we would refuse
to do exclusive deals with people.
But I would explain to people,
"Well, we don't really do exclusive deals,
"but we only have the capacity
"to work with one, and
it's going to be you."
Right?
There are other ways of
achieving those kinds of things.
So I'd be careful to conclude
that you should do a small thing.
All success starts from doing
one thing really, really well,
but you'll recruit better
with a broader vision
that's credible and
that you can articulate.
But go back to that, selling the dream.
What you do is selling a dream.
If you can't sell the dream,
then you're not going to be successful.
I've received so many
different kinds of advice
I don't know where to start.
One that comes to mind is to have a coach.
Our board member in 2002, John Doerr,
said, "You need a coach."
And I said, well, I don't need a coach,
I'm an established CEO,
why would I need a coach?
Is something wrong?
He said, "No, no, no, you need a coach.
"Everybody needs a coach."
So Bill Campbell became my coach,
and it served Google very well.
Every famous athlete,
every famous performer,
has somebody who's a coach.
Somebody who can watch
what they're doing and say,
"Is that what you really meant?
"Did you really do that?"
And give them perspective.
The one thing people are never good at
is seeing themselves as others see them.
A coach really, really helps.
So one of the ideas that
we had a few years ago
was that we would be better off
with more and more
people in our ecosystem.
And the best way to do that
is to essentially help
entrepreneurs be successful.
It doesn't mean they're captive to us,
they're still going to
use competitor products,
and competitor ad systems
and competitor platforms.
But it seems one of the things that people
don't understand when they view business
is they assume that business
is, how to describe it,
it's a zero sum game.
That if company A wins, company B loses.
I'll tell you that when Yahoo was young
and Terry Semel was running it,
whenever he and his
company would win a deal,
I would call him to congratulate him.
And whenever we would win a deal,
he would call me to congratulate me.
And by the way, we were tough competitors.
Why would we do that?
Because we both understood
that we were building
a larger market.
So you can understand our
goal as philanthropic,
you can understand it as making
the world a better place,
but you can also understand
it as self-interested,
in that building more people
who understand the concepts
of network computing and
platforms and so forth
benefits everyone, including Google.
20% time was a rule invented,
again, when I started there,
there were two actually interesting.
One was "don't be evil", and
the second one was "20% time."
"Don't be evil" I thought was a joke.
'Cause I mean, nobody here is evil.
I don't want to be evil,
you don't want to be evil.
And so I was sitting in the
original conference room
in this small building where we started,
and there's conversation
about ad targeting
and a particular ad click,
and one of the engineers,
his name is Ron, pounds the table,
and said, "That would be evil!"
And I'm like, oh, okay,
what just happened?
And the whole mood of the room changes,
and there's this huge debate over
whether that's evil or not.
And ultimately, they didn't do the change.
And so I thought, what's
the analogy there?
And the analogy was, it's
the kanban system, right?
In Japan, the notion that any employee
can stop the line if they
see a poor quality thing.
And it works, 'cause of shared values.
Strong shared values, a
strong buy into principles,
takes you far.
I think that helped us.
And that, I think it may
or may not be true today
that the company has that feeling,
but certainly its history is clearly that.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Sam Borsten asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you, and why.
What did you learn from this?
What are you going to change
in your business or your life
after watching this video?
Leave it in the comments, and
I will join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jim Firaben.
Jim, thank you so much for buying my book,
it really means a lot to me.
For those of those you watching,
if you want your chance at a
shout out in a future video,
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is!
And I'll see you soon.
- I learned a lot from our founders.
And one of the things I learned was
ask the impossible and really dream big.
What you'll learn about
people is if you paint
a very broad vision, you attract people
who really want to make it happen,
'cause they're dreamers, too.
So you can inspire people,
and with that inspiration,
you get the smartest people,
and they deal with a lot of stuff.
- But can an organization like Google,
which espouses the idea
that you're going to give
people in the organization
15 or 20% of their time
to do almost anything they
want, in terms of innovation,
can that system work in smaller companies?
Can that system work in any company?
Is that a leadership tenant that can work
across a broad range of companies?
- Well, in fact, it worked at
Google when Google was tiny.
So the answer is yes, it
does work in small companies.
Remember, we give this to engineers,
and engineers are not that clever.
If they're going to work on
something in their 20% time,
it's going to be something
that's pretty related
to their training and their knowledge.
And that's why it's so powerful.
Very, very few people sort
of get off the reservation
and do something completely different
from technology and so
forth, and if they did,
we would encourage it.
- Has something manifested you can recall
come from just that kind of incubation?
- Virtually all of the
interesting apps now
came from a combination of an acquisition
and a 20% time.
If you look at Maps, if
you look at Google Earth,
if you look at Chrome and Android,
all of them came from
somebody trying something,
identifying something,
and then we would say,
we have all these 20% timers
but we need a real group!
And the fastest way to do that was to
create a real group or buy a company.
I want to offer a cautionary tale.
And again, having both read your book
and also the notes that you
kindly sent me before this,
if you don't understand the subtlety here,
you would conclude that the
correct thing to do is to grow
everything as fast as you
possibly can, everywhere.
Right?
So let's just make as many engineers,
as many salespeople, as many
products, and so on and so on.
That completely does not work.
And it doesn't work because
no product shall ship
before it actually works.
Right?
And the way you build great products
is you have small teams
with strong leaders,
who obsess over trade-offs,
and they push things off,
and they say, "We've got to get it done,"
and they put a lot of
pressure on the team.
They work all night, and
they produce a product
that just barely works.
The original, I'll use
non-Google examples,
the original iPod just barely worked.
Look at what it became.
Try, people, remember the original iPhone.
No apps, right?
Everyone's forgotten that.
Just barely worked.
But it just was just the right combination
to create an enormous
franchise that's now 70%
of the revenue of the world's
most valuable company.
I was talking to Travis Kalanick, we are
major investors inside of Uber,
so we have good relationships with Uber.
And his description of Uber
was that he understood scaling,
but the product, the app, wasn't ready.
So you have to sort of
have judgment about when
the product is ready to scale against it.
And so we would debate
this over and over again.
And so Larry and Sergey
would play tricks on me.
So a typical example
would be, I would say,
we're not strong enough
to take on Microsoft.
And they wanted to do an
operating system and a browser.
And I said, there's no
scenario where we'll ever do
an operating system and a browser.
'Cause Microsoft will kill us,
and I don't want to get killed.
We're a small company, and
yes, yes, you're very smart,
and yes, yes, we're full of smart people,
and yes, yes, we have lots of revenue;
these guys can kill us.
'Cause I'd been previously
killed in previous jobs.
And so they hired somebody to improve
the performance of Firefox.
Six months later, I'm
called down to one office,
and this person who's supposed to improve
the performance of Firefox
has managed to invent Chrome.
Shocking.
(audience laughter)
And I say, well how long
have you been doing this?
"Well, I've been doing it on the side."
No you haven't, you've done it full-time.
"Well, yeah, you know, I
had three other people."
Okay, well, how many
more people do you have?
"Oh, 10 more people."
Well, okay, did Larry and
Sergey know about this?
"Larry and Sergey encouraged it."
Those assholes, right?
(loud laughter)
I knew it!
I knew they were going around me, right?
Okay?
Then I said, well, we can't
do an operating system,
so they bought this
company called Android,
and they said, "Yeah,
it's just for smartphones,
"it's software for smartphones,
don't worry, Eric."
Today Android is 1.4 billion
plus operating systems used,
largest number of operating
systems in the world,
Chrome is the largest and
most successful browser.
So, maybe the lesson to
learn in management is
I'm just wrong all the time.
But the secret was, you sort
of, you have to have judgment
as to when these things can scale, right?
And I can give you plenty
of negative examples.
An obvious one is Wave.
It was a complicated email product
that we launched to great fanfare,
and we watched its adoption rate.
Marissa had this rule,
which is a good rule,
that you cannot, at
Google, you cannot tell
how successful a product is
until the first six months.
Because what happens is you
get this adoption cycle,
and everyone loves the product,
'cause everyone tests it,
and then you watch what happens.
And the great products, you know,
they're bumpy, but they go up.
Well, this is what it
looked like, like this.
So it took Eric, your friendly CEO,
18 months of going down, straight down,
before the project was canceled.
So again, lack of due diligence lasts.
The reason I'm answering your question
in the Blitz growth argument by saying
you've got to have the
products that you can scale.
If you have the products that can scale,
the thing that's new is
you can scale very quickly.
The Uber example.
Once you have an app and a business model
that more or less works,
there's no reason why you
shouldn't go global and wide.
Successful companies are a set of things.
So Google was and is this
remarkable technical platform;
it also was a new way
of doing advertising.
ROI-based advertising.
And if you go back to your career
and look at what you've
done in sales for us,
what you did at Oracle, what
I did at these other jobs,
they all had the property that you had
an interesting platform
that the technologists saw,
and you also had a monetization model.
The next generation of that is going to be
applications monetization,
web services monetization,
the way these developers,
this new generation
can make money.
'Cause ultimately, if they
want to be very successful,
there has to be revenue
coming in to focus everything.
So I think, for me, the
fact that we were able
to combine those was
both the hardest thing,
but also the most powerful thing.
Because when the two work together,
it happens very, very quickly.